this is a question i ask of everybody i
talk to and i i'm dying to know the
answer from you conan o'brien are you
gonna
what if your question is can i have some
money no god
this is a question i ask everybody
could i have three hundred
[Laughter]
i just do a volume business of asking
people for money
you know my my question to you is uh
conan o'brien what is your favorite
dinosaur
oh
um wow well uh you know i hate to i used
to be the t-rex until you said t-rex and
now i think i have to go with diplodocus
cause it's the only other name i can
remember that's a good name that's a
great dinosaur which one is diplodocus
it is it is one of the longest of the
sauropods so you mentioned
before i liked it because i'm very long
and uh the diplodocus is very long and
it lives in the water doesn't it no no
no actually they they lived across the
plains and savannahs uh they they were
actually they walked around in huge
force and they could whip their tails so
fast it could like sound like thunder as
they walked around but uh diplodocus uh
it was a mess i'm sorry excuse me sir
diplodocus actually they're both right
it's crazy this is damn it you don't you
i wanted to be in i want i wanted to be
an ass and correct you
do you say diplodocus it's it's a it's a
tomato tomato situation diplodocus or
diplodocus it comes from the greek and
that jerk stavros uh when he
it's from it means double beam it's
based on the way that the bones of the
tail look and they call it the
diplodocus or cloticus whichever way you
want to do it and uh they they say both
interchangeably well now i say
deploticus lovely
uh i just want to be different well
that's my that's my pick that's my pick
for favorite dinosaur that's an
excellent choice um when i showed this
duckbill before you said this dinosaur
kind of looked like you
and well just that that hair yeah i i
feel like i got a better one i think i
have something else that that kind of
fits the the conan bill a little bit
more uh this is a dinosaur called
therizinosaurus oh wow very tall it's
got this really it's really great uh
proportions it's got the long arms it's
got the shimmering orange hair down the
side and then what i like about this one
is that uh it can also do the string
dance oh look at that
when the dance is over it's got its own
scissors built in it can just cut the
string
okay you know what's clear to me now you
are in no way a scientist you are this
you're a prop comic you're a prop comic
you're the gallagher of paleontology
yeah you're gallagher 3. your house is
just filled with toys
and
and and kooky sight gags conan if they
make sounds they're toys if they don't
they're
models how long have you lived alone i'm
just curious
no uh actually you know i've uh i've
been married for for nine years now and
she's fantastic what's up with all of it
and she loves it it's important that you
too do not go extinct
you know i'm gonna say i'm gonna no i i
am i am a fan of yours i love people
that know stuff i really do i love
people that uh have educated themselves
and and know things and also you're very
upbeat about what you do which is really
infectious and uh and i think it's very
cool i think it's very cool and i say i
say go out and get
more dinosaur replicas i wouldn't i
didn't want to say toys he said get more
[Laughter]
not enough dinosaurs
[Laughter]
uh well jimmy it was a pleasure meeting
you seriously and uh best of luck to you
and i hope our paths cross someday and i
hope you find your dinosaur i really do
conan it's been an honor thank you so
much for having me on it's been an
absolute pleasure i'll see you around
next time thanks jimmy
and jimmy by the way you've got a great
uh jack black energy you really do i've
known jack for a long time but you've
got that same kind of and that's a
compliment i try to keep it loosey
goosey cones
i knew it jack take off that mask